So there's been a building sort of chorus
of people both on the Trumpy and Right.
And also some on the anti Biden left who have
just been insisting that Joe Biden can't possibly
hold it together.
In an interview, he can't possibly hold it
together under questioning from reporters.
And we had finally some examples that we can
look at.
Joe Biden was interviewed on ABC News over
the weekend alongside his running mate, Kamala
Harris.
This was the first joint interview that they
did, I believe.
And the interview was remarkable in how unremarkable
it was from the standpoint of the hysteria
and the hyperbole and the craziness that we've
become used to under Donald Trump.
It was just like a boring political interview.
Joe Biden answered questions and he answered
follow up questions.
And he sounded like a politician for better
or worse, and was completely coherent like
it would.
This would not normally be news, but it's
news when you have people on both sides anticipating
that Joe Biden would devolve into a stuttering.
Yes.
He has an actual stutter, incoherent mess,
unable to make any point whatsoever.
And in fact, I enjoyed the interview, not
so much, because I just agree with every policy
decision that is being made by this platform,
the Biden Harris platform.
But because it was just normal and we've been
hoping for normal for so long.
So let's look at some clips here.
Is Joe Biden saying he would do a national
shut down or recommend one if public health
officials said it was the right idea for dealing
with coronavirus?
Remember, it's ultimately up to governors.
What the president can do is recommend and
say, hey, guys, let's all do this.
And remember that we still have a raging pandemic,
over 180000 deaths as Donald Trump continues
to insist we've done and are doing really
well with the virus.
Here is Joe Biden sworn in come January.
And we have corona virus and the flu combining,
which many scientists have said is a real
possibility.
Would you be prepared to shut this country
down again?
I would be prepared to do it every takes to
save lives because we cannot get the country
moving until we control the virus.
That is the fundamental flaw of this administration's
thinking to begin with.
In order to keep the country running and moving
and the economy growing and people employed,
you have fixed the virus.
You have to deal with the virus.
So if the scientists say, shut it down, I
would shut it down.
I would listen to the scientists.
Now, immediately, you had people come out
and say, oh, my God, what a socialist authoritarian.
He wants no country.
He wants no economy.
He wants no businesses.
Come on, guys.
Come on.
Haven't we learned enough at this point?
Haven't we seen what happened in other countries
versus in the United States when people wore
masks and they took social distancing seriously?
And when you have to shut down sectors of
the economy temporarily, you do it, but then
you're able to reopen.
Biden is not saying any.
If you're shocked that what Biden's saying,
then then essentially you're saying the whole
world handled it incorrectly.
We we handled it correctly.
And we have one of the highest per capita
death rates in the world.
Biden is just being sensible.
This is a medical situation, just a candidate
recognizing that distinguishes them from Donald
Trump.
We have to defer to public health and medical
officials.
That's it.
That's what we need in this country.
And people are going crazy about authoritarian
Joe Biden.
Now, on top of that, had we done a two month
coordinated shutdown, meaning essential businesses,
only everybody wears masks.
No school back in April or May, we never would
have gotten to where we are today, which is
in an emergency situation with one of the
worst coronavirus responses in the world.
People are reacting to Biden like he's the
outlier.
Biden is just saying, let's do what the rest
of the world figured out months ago.
No more, no less.
Then Joe Biden is asked because, again, Trump
has been criticizing Biden for being in his
basement.
Joe Biden was asked, can you win a presidential
election from your house?
Take a look.
I understand the restrictions have covered
and campaigning in this time, but can you
win a presidential election from home?
We will.
We're going to follow the science, what the
scientists tell us.
We've been able to travel places where we've
been able to do it in a way that we don't
cause the congregation of large numbers of
people.
Look what happens.
What's happened with his his events?
People die.
People get together.
They don't wear masks that end up getting
cold.
They end up dying.
So when you hear the president say this guy's.
Afraid to leave his basement.
Guess what?
I have left my basement.
And but here on the meantime, 500 million
people have watched what I've done out of
my basement.
And guess what, people are listening.
People are listening.
It's about being responsible.
I really think that this is creating controversy
where there is no controversy here.
And what's going to be really interesting
is for three and a half years, we've had this
narrative from Trump that the fake news media
is all against him.
All the media is against them except Fox News
and even Fox News sometimes is against them.
So you've got to go to A.N. to find fair media.
What a lot of people have forgotten.
I have not forgotten it.
Is that the myth of the liberal media is a
myth.
This is a corporatist media with a pension
for salaciousness and controversy.
And right away, they are taking hook, line
and sinker every narrative set by Trump here.
They're asking about Biden in his basement.
Guys, there's a pandemic.
Biden's being responsible.
That's it.
Okay.
And then they continue to take debate the
bait.
Corporate media does by asking Biden about
the attacks Donald Trump has been making against
Biden on his cognitive fitness.
Now, I happen to think it's fair when you
have candidates that are in their 70s, Trump
now mid 70s, Biden closer to 80.
It's totally reasonable to ask about cognitive
fitness.
But what's fascinating here is that corporate,
supposedly fake news, left leaning corporate
media, they're taking Trump's bait on every
one of these issues, Biden in the basement
and now Biden's cognitive fitness.
I want to turn to the blistering attacks we've
seen from President Trump just this week alone
on your mental fitness, whether you're up
for the job.
His campaign has called you diminished.
And I'm curious how you'd respond to that.
Watch me, Mr. President.
Watch me.
Look at us both.
What we say, what we do, what we control,
what we know, what kind of shape we're in.
Come on.
Look, I think it's a legitimate question to
ask anybody over 70 years or whether or not
they're fit and whether they're ready.
But I just hoping I can say the American people.
It's a legitimate question to ask anybody.
Watch me.
Let's put the attacks aside then.
The American people remember Ronald Reagan
was 77 when he left office.
He would be 78 entering office.
And you have said yourself that you are a
transition candidate.
Does that mean a one term president?
What is it?
No, it doesn't mean so.
You're leaving open the possibility you'll
serve eight years?
Absolutely.
OK.
So Joe Biden handling it perfectly, perfectly
well.
And I do think much like before the Bernie
Biden debate, you had all these people expecting,
oh, my God, if Biden's up against Bernie one
on one, Biden's going to collapse.
And of course, he didn't.
And he went on to win the primary.
They were disappointed.
And I think they're going to be disappointed
again in debates against Trump if they happen.
I don't expect any kind of collapse from Joe
Biden.
Biden also was interviewed by ABC.
Is Robin Roberts asked about choosing Kamala
Harris?
And again, this is not a particularly newsworthy
clip.
It's just notable that Joe Biden is normal.
He's able to articulate why he selected Kamala
Harris.
He's able to speak in complete compound sentences.
We've just become unaccustomed to a take a
look.
There is a connection there that I'm going
to talk more about when it comes to BO and
and other aspects of family.
You alluded, Mr. Vice President, about the
fact that you made it clear early on that
you were going to select a woman to be your
running mate.
You select a woman of color.
Did you do that to rally your base?
Did you feel pressure to select a black woman?
No, I didn't feel pressure to select a black
woman.
But what I do think and I've said it before
and you've heard me say that probably you
said on your show with you.
Is that the government should look like the
people look like the country.
51 percent of the people in this country are
women.
That expression goes.
Women hold up half the sky.
And in order to be able to succeed, you've
got to be dealt in across the board.
And no matter what you say, you cannot I cannot
understand and fully appreciate what it means
to walk in her shoes, to be an African-American
woman with an American background, child and
immigrants.
She can't assume exactly what it's like to
walk in my shoes.
Well, we do know is we have the same value
set.
And I really mean that.
And so it was it was easy for me.
It was an easy decision to make.
Although there are enormous number of really
qualified women, I spoke to every single woman
that was on the list before.
And as the day I made the choice before they
was announced, I called every single one of
them.
So what was the tipping point?
The tipping point was I was it was the race,
several things, but it just seemed to fit
the closest and the best.
I thought I understood.
And I think I understand her where she comes
from, what her instincts are, her her character.
I watched her take on the Big Bang.
I watched her take on the gun lobby, I watched
her the way she was a prosecutor, I've watched
her as the United States senator.
Isn't this so weird that Joe Biden just answers
questions and stays on topic and doesn't ramble
and and again uses compound sentences now?
Then asked whether she still agrees with her
prior call for more police officers on the
streets, which has been really the big liability
for Kamala Harris.
She doesn't directly answer, as politicians
often avoid doing.
Instead, she praises Black Lives Matter as
important in a national conversation about
policing.
And you know the name that you have, Comilla
top cop and the book that you wrote 10 years
ago, Smart on Crime, where you conclude by
saying that you wanted to see more police
on the street.
Do you still feel that way?
Listen, I think that there is no question.
First of all, when I wrote that book, We Black
Lives Matter did not exist.
And I give full credit to the brilliance of
that movement in terms of what it has done
to advance a conversation that needed to happen
a long time ago.
What Black Lives Matter has done as a movement
has been to be a counter force against a very
entrenched status quo around the criminal
justice system in America.
And that's why I'm so excited about what we
can do in terms of a new administration in
the White House.
Okay, so Kamala Harris is sort of equivocating.
She's saying Black Lives Matter is good.
She's saying, well, what I did before was
a while ago.
You can't really explain it any differently
other than to say I was attorney general at
the time and I was doing my job.
This is this is standard politics and we don't
have to like it.
But again, it's not about whether you accept
Carmella's answer.
It's about the reality that these are just
normal people who relate to the media normally,
who relate to their families normally, who
can complete a thought.
And that has been so missing for years in
this country.
Meanwhile, Donald Trump did not have a very
good week.
And let's talk about that next